Y'all want some games?
Who provides the most quality original gameplay?
That's right!
ME MOTHERFUCKER!
Look at all these fuckers playing the same goddamn game LIKE A BUNCH OF LOSERS
*spits*
Disgusting!
Be creative!
Be original!
and for fucks' sake
*brainfart*
have some goddamn integrity
*SWAG*
*swag hurt eye*
*different swag*
you bitch
*get rekt*
a- anyway today we're gonna play 10 second tattoo
this is pretty exciting because we're probably the first one to have ever played this game ever
in the video game universe
*EARTHQUICK*
Ten Second Tattoo, baby
*Too much Mtn Dew*
I've never been a tattoo artist before but
I have at least
two- tattoos so that means
IT MEANS I'M BETTER THAN ALL THESE PUSSY ASS!
BET THEY WOULDN'T EVEN GET A TEN-SECOND TATTOO!
I'D GET A TEN SECOND TATTOO ON MAH FUCKIN' ASS!
"Hey, I'm looking to get a cartoon flag"
How does it work
OH SHIT
Oh Mah Gawd
A cartoon flag
Lemme just fill that in for ya
Aaaand
Omg
*laughs* ahahahahahahah
ahh
uhh
halp
"I've given this a lot of thought, I need a thorny squid."
Papa Poods gotchur back
*my lips are tasty*
This looks nothing like a fucking squid.
Are you fucking kidding me..
"I've made a huge mistake"
Yea you're fucked.
*laughs* hnghts
"Do a Satanic sea monster"
Dude this is way too HARD!!!
like mah dick
Oh I know
I got a good idea
*buzzzz*
And then the gills
Dude that is so cool man!
You look fucking awesome!
another one
WUT DA FUK
PANIC!!
Alright
I'll do a keut-ass fucking cat
Heyyy! That's pretty good
*Laughs-pewds is proud of his cat*
That is a happy cat man.. 8D
I want a geometric fruit basket! :D
Uuhh..
Aw! Oh shit! :0 Um..
I've been wanting this FOREVER!, a sexy kitten! ;D *wtf?*
Holy shit, me too :D
Let's make this, and let's make this right! 8)
Groovy music intensifies
THE GROOVIEST MUSIC EVER :D
OH YEAH PEWDS...
PFFTAHAHAHAHAHAHA
AWH MAN! :D
AWWH YEAH!!
You look fucking man!! YOU'RE WELCOME! :D
Quick! What's the worse tattoo you could possibly get..
Done! :D
PPFFFTAHAHAHAHAHAHA x'D
Actually i'll take that back, i'll take that back.. That's not funny xD
THIS IS THE WORSE TATTOO YOU WOULD POSSIBLY GET! :D
How about.. Like just crying...
A pair of balls
Okay, we clearly lost all form of committee at this point :T
Next game it's called "The body"
It's supposed to be sad.. :(
Alright! I'm walkin' home..
With my coat, my tre- trench coat in the back...
It's a pr- pretentious little art game..
Ayyyyy i was- ehwas-eh, we're walkin'.. That's how you walk!
Just move your knees..
Brake your ankles every time you take a step! :D
Aaand now we're back tooo the..
What i now think is a body back! :D
I'm pretty sure it's a body back! o.o
Also and you can make anything sad to Max Ritcher alright?
Like i'll prove it to yah..
Cute cats..
Nouh.. Look at those cute cats... So cute O_O
Look at his furry little fur head *-*
This one looks like it begs for food D: I bet it's homeless T_T
This one is clearly dying!
This one wanted to become, a lumber jack..
This one was just straight up weab..
Aand.. This cat...
I'm pretty sure this cat is possessed by satan ._.
Alright that was uhhh.. Kinda ruin it, didn't i? xD
Pfftahaha x'D
That was rid..
Alright..Next time we'll amours our self in a better move- NEXT GAME PLEA-
Wtf Pewds? xD
We're gonna do a horror game! :D
This one takes places in a Swedish modern home! :D
Game's called "Notes of obsession"..
Wow.. See this look really fuckin' cool man O_O
This look amaaazing! :D
This remind me of... Allison, Road or whatever.. o.o
Is that..Oh wow O.O
This is so immersive!
That is a nice ass couch, looks uncomfortable a bit..
THIS IS SO DOPE!! :D
And i never use that word, you know it's legit man! x'D
Alright what we've got here...
Hand-boken for... Nyb-(What?._.)
Okay so handbook for New-Newrlie, parents
Fuck me man, i could've...
OH MY GOD..
6 Years u_u
6 years i've played horror games..
I still get scared... By a shutting door :D (Gg Poods xD)
Hey look at this!
I'm living the Swedish dream man! Good for you man! :D
I LOOVE THIS- THE- THE FEEL OF THIS..
Like.. You really feel like you're exploring a home!
And so far...
It's fun! :)
So far...
I mean exploring in games is fun! x'D
As long it doesn't go on for too long -_-
It's goin' on for too long isn't it? -__-
JESUS CHRIST I'M BORED .-.
This feels.. Oddly familiar
Like it's freaking me out man, i don't like it D:
Okay something's making that noise! O_O
Woow O.O
So i think.. By looking at the hands, we're a female =.=
This is so cool! O_O
Waat.. Does that mean?! o.o
Now why would i do that?..
I've never seen anything like this!
Okay i interacted with a satanic symbol...
WHAT THE FUCK!?
OH MY GAAAAAHHHHHHH..
What am i doin?! D:
How about the closet? o.o
*Gasps* Wow :<
Hello? =^=
How did this happened? D:
Am i supposed to use this? O__O
Jeeesus...
Oh oh OH OHH! D:
Staawp.. :<
Fuckin' fuck T_T
I luv u Poods u_u
I ain't gonna- I love you too! T_T
Why did you leave me? D:
'Cause of that BOOTEEH!! 8D
A'ight now we can go..
Wait, so the room just resets.. What the fuck man? D:
This is some quality fuckin' Ikea furniture, and i can appriciate that.. You know what i mean? x'D
You know what i mean? You know- OHH GOD! O_O
What?!..
What, am i a little boy now? *Gasps* Or a little girl?... Noo T_T No..
*GASPS* GGHAHHH! D8
That's- that was some sick skrillex.... Beat drop man.. o.o
Isn't this how the game started? :l
But i have the thing..
Whooaaat..
I swear i heard it over here... There is it..
AAAAHHH
WAT DA FAK IS DATTT!????!
AAAAAAHHHGHHH!!
What da fok man.. Q_Q
This is so fuckin' awesome..
This game man...
I've not played a horror game this good in a long time..
A'ight two more...
Two more..
Com'on buddeh, com'on where are yeh?..
Ooohhhh... It's coming upstairs T__T
*Gasps*
Dat ass man, it's so fuckin' nice! 8)
Aahh D:
*GASPS* GHAAAHHH! DX
*Poods falls*
JESUSSS CHRISST WHAT THE FUUCK!!
There it is...
Two more.. Oh god i love you, i need you D:
*GASPS*
What was that?..
Ughh..Fuck meh i'm such a bitch T_T
What's that? =_=
There it is!
Oh we just got one more babeh! :D
Oh baby a triple.. 8)
Why did i say that?..
It's gone to that point..
FUCKIN' ASSHOLE..
Listen man, just 'cause you don't have an ass doesn't mean you have to be an ass..
#Pewdiepie2016
Uh oh god..
(HEADPHONE USERS WARNING! O_O)
(Told y'all :D)
Oh god we better hurry the fuck up!
Here we go, take the knife!
Heeell yeaaah! 8D
You know what're we gonna do with this shit! x'D
OOHH IT'S KINDA DAMN, BITCH! :D
OWWWW..
That was fuckin' amazing!
Hey, look at that.. Three free games!
Quality shit man! :D
But anyway thank you so much for watching this episode! :D
If you enjoyed as always, as always.. Go ahead leave a like
Because that means i get more likes..
Thank so much for watching..
And as always, see you tomorrow with a new episode
And remember Bros..
"Just 'cause you don't have an asshole, doesn't mean you have to be one!" :D *Brofist*
*Outro-click for more videos!*